un record pour rien à rien à grande
autorité et la chanson d'espoir si tôt à
rien la grande et cartonne en ce moment
ouais ouais ouais on la quitte moi
j'aime bien les cheveux gris comme ça
pour les meufs un bon bah ouais j'adore
je trouve que c'est un bon des liens
valeur de marché les timbres et les
trois pires preuve les trois heures
place du hit parade américain
exact alors là pas les cheveux gris
juste une photo à les dépanner joli cd
génique donc après avoir égalé un record
des beatles qui est datée de 10 964 elle
a encore fait parler d'elle vous aimez
bien rien à glander vous en tant que
chanteur donc en réalité qui la produit
arrière et grandissent et moi non je ne
sais pas qui l'a produit je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que je m'étais
arrêté à rihanna enfin ca donc c'est pas
du tout n'a rien à vendre et c'est
hispanique ou c'est rihanna grande et
houbara n'avait et n'a pas joué la
montre et c'est là bas vous allez voir
on va vous faire belle et a rien à
garder ces noms là tu vois pas frères
heureusement que tu es venue dans
l'émission est ce que toi tu été
rachetée à edith piaf pourquoi mon
frérot à lola pour les allez on y va
c'est incontestable la star la plus en
vue du moment est américaine et elle
s'appelle ariana grande baie la
chanteuse pop est en train de pulvériser
un à un tous les records possibles en
terme de popularité pour un artiste
après la sortie de son album thank you
next qui la semaine dernière a vu trois
de ses titres classés simultanément aux
trois premières places des charts
américains
c'est maintenant au tour des réseaux
sociaux de s'affoler face à la
popularité de la jeune femme
ainsi cette semaine avec ses 146 5
millions d'abonnés a rien à glander
dépasser les négos l'aise et devient la
personnalité féminine la plus suivis au
monde
côté record sur youtube le recordman
toutes catégories reste le chanteur
portoricain luis fonsi en featuring avec
daddy yankee qui avec l'argent sont des
spas sitôt viennent de dépasser le cap
des 6 milliards de vues sur youtube
battant ainsi le record du clip le plus
visionné de l'histoire de la plateforme
ce pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beauté cette bataille mais ouais mais
j'ai reçu un diable et bravo je sais ce
qu'il a dit qu'elle gère un diable et
oui vous m'avez franchement surpris bras
bon vous devenez vous oui si on peut
revenir sur un anagramme des mois je
suis ravi que qu'elle fasse un succès
planétaire parce qu'elle montre aux
jeunes filles et aux femmes
on n'est pas obligé d'être agressive ni
vulgaire ni à outrance à poil pour être
montré qu'on peut couper les choses vont
mieux conduire à des modèles n'est pas
d'accord humaine est pas l ai pas vu
hier comme rihanna n'est pas agréé
beaucoup plus vulgaire que rihanna
excuses à laure et la même voiture a dit
moi je moi je trouve que c'est une it
girl pour qu a beaucoup de talent mais
qui ne m'intéresse pas je la trouve
totalement stéréotypées
on dira un filtre snap il ya tout en
compte ou ring en fossiles pour moi
aucun intérêt rien n'est réglé après
voilà l habitat l'on est